last time you were here you were just
getting used to living in Nashville
right so how do you how do you love it I
need to take stock and Spanx
um I don't know how people there's some
great food yeah I lived there for 12
years Kelly yeah okay Hattie B's yeah
hot chicken yeah um biscuit love the
biscuits are like a crepe I don't know
what I've renamed um you're gonna
appreciate this what I sat down and put
my jeans on for today and I was like oh
because I've just come back the top on
my jeans like oh the muffin top yes I
think we should do that I mean I've
heard of it I don't I don't have it oh a
muffin top it's a smooth sailing right
here but well not too yeah because I'm
spanks to me but you've got to rewrite
the song and I think I know what it's
going to be instead of Rocky Top okay
yes
I'm like oh my God I gotta be taped I
know it's hard that's a hard place
because there's so many great
restaurants I mean like top-notch chefs
like from like TV shows that have I can
oh my God I think forgetting what I'm
gonna tell you the break but it's an
Indian one and it's amazing actually I
shouldn't tell you but it's so good
anyway I have heard though speaking of
food
um you're kind of classy and trashy so
apparently you love 7-Eleven food I do
all right I do so is this just for like
road trip occasions or just like any day
that ends in y it started out that way
okay and it evolved into I'm kind of
feeling like I need a snack on the way
to Kelly Clarkson so I'm gonna stop at
7-Eleven get a piece of pizza okay their
pizzas are great y'all also they're hot
dogs they just turn them around you can
get it however you want I think they're
known for the slurpee machine right yeah
yeah I love the Slurpee yeah um and I'm
always mad when you can't get the coke
to work and always y'all notice that and
you go walk in the coke broken y'all
notice
I know totally but um yeah you get all
kinds of food every snack you want you
can get a light bulb you can get a piece
of pizza you know
we were thinking more like tea and
crumpets I'm like no not me I love it
some days yeah but that's good yes
exactly
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going
[Music]